what I would like to see is people who
go to Washington not with an inset of
instructions to never compromise but you
go to Washington to compromise could you
imagine if this country which had vast
sectional differences in agrarian South
industrial north different states or
colonies with different interests some
religious some were commercial getting
together in forming a country humanity
if you went to the convention and each
one came with a mandate and a commitment
to never to stay on the fringe of what
his leg of his specific electorate
commanded and to go there and would you
have a country and you know something I
have confidence in the in the Republic
and so I think it will get will surmount
it but if it kept on like this we
wouldn't have a country now so to me I
would like to see I'm for the moderate
that's open to compromising and have it
coming out with a sit with a stable set
of principles it sounds like you're
asking like Bloomberg to run for
president no it's not I'll tell you we
get up we get you know we get a number
of you know there's a lot of focus on
and you know New York billionaires these
days but my favorite one is not running
that compromise is not a bad word
compromise is what democracy is all
about that you get most of the people
get a good percentage of what they want
a handful of people on the to sigmaz out
get almost nothing and then that's the
way we come together remove but let me
get to give you a thought Stephanie we
keep thinking the wrong thing when we
pick the elected leaders particularly
the presidents of the United States
governors of the states and may as the
cities these are not policy jobs these
are executive jobs you have to pick
somebody that knows how to run the
railroad making blocking and tackling
making sure when you throw the switch
the lights come on and then turn the
fuss at the water comes out at the
federal level you've got to make sure
that we control our borders and we so
fun we get the right leadership to get
the right weapons for our troops and get
great people to come and work as
secretaries and all the different
cabinet officers policy is terribly
important but no executive can no put no
president governor may occur
have all the policies themselves they've
got to get people to come and help them
formulate them on all the other topics
that's what an executive does